THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WE'RE HOLDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM 2100
OF THE SWING SPACE. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2100. SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING, WE ONCE AGAIN, WE HAVE
50% OF THE REPUBLICANS HERE. AND
ABOUT ABOUT 23% OF THE
DEMOCRATS. SO, WE ARE GOING TO,
I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE BILLS
THAT ARE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
, AND I'M GOING TO NOTE THAT
FILE, NUMBER FOUR, AB 2898 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND WILL ACTUALLY BE
HEARD TODAY. SO THE FOLLOWING 14
BILLS, ARE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS.
FILM NUMBER ONE AB 1880 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS. FILM
NUMBER TWO AB 2011 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN. FILM NUMBER
THREE AB 2484 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN. FILM NUMBER FIVE AB 375
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES. FILM
NUMBER SIX AB 1966 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES. FILM NUMBER SEVEN
AB 1879 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB 1903 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCINI. FILM NUMBER NINE AB
1916 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN WITH AMENDMENTS.
FILM NUMBER TEN AB 2397 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI. FILM
NUMBER 11 AB 1852 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO. FILM NUMBER 12
AB 2024 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO. FILM NUMBER 13 AB 661
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON. FILM NUMBER 14 AB
1974 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. FILM NUMBER 17 AB
1824 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA
THAT CONCLUDES THE. LET ME SEE
IF THAT CONCLUDES. THAT
CONCLUDES THE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, WE DO
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO APPEAR HERE
AS QUICKLY AS THEY CAN, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED AS A IF
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR. WE'RE GOING
TO PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'M SORRY.
LACKING MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY,
I'M GOING TO PRESENT SB 3072 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AND I WANT TO. OH, HERE WE HAVE
ONE. OKAY SO REMEMBER CARILLO.
SO, AND I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
SENATOR ROTH HERE. SENATOR ROTH,
WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE YOU HERE
ONCE AGAIN. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO. YOU HAVE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, AB 2898, THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NO LONGER IS. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 28 TO 98, MY
PRIORITIES IN THE MY LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE HAVE ALWAYS INCLUDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, HOUSING AND
CLIMATE JUSTICE AS KEY PILLARS.
AB 29 2898 IS A GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE REQUESTED BILL MAKING A
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGE TO AB
1317, THE UNBUNDLING PARKING LAW
FROM LAST YEAR THAT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW AB 1317, REQUIRES
OWNERS OF NEW MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTIES OF 16 UNITS OR MORE
IN TEN COUNTIES TO LEASE PARKING
AS SEPARATE AND OPTIONAL
EXPENSES TO THEIR TENANTS. THIS
BILL EXEMPTS ANY RESIDENTIAL
UNIT LEASED TO A TENANT WITH WHO
RECEIVED A FEDERAL HOUSING
CHOICE VOUCHER, INCLUDING A
FEDERAL VETERANS AFFAIRS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING VOUCHER FROM
THE UNBUNDLING PARKING LAW.
AFTER THE AB 1317 PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE, THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO
EXEMPT VOUCHER HOLDERS GIVING
FEDERAL REGULATIONS, PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES DETERMINE
DETERMINE A PAYMENT STANDARD,
THE AMOUNT GENERALLY NEEDED TO
RENT A MODERATELY PRICED
DWELLING IN THE LOCAL HOUSING
MARKET. THE PAYMENT STANDARD
DETERMINES HOW MUCH ASSISTANCE A
FEDERAL HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
RECEIVES. FAS DON'T INCLUDE
UNBUNDLED COSTS IN THE PAYMENT
STANDARD, SO VOUCHER HOLDERS
PAID FOR THESE EXPENSES OUT OF
POCKET. THIS ADDITIONAL EXPENSE
IS AN ISSUE FOR FEDERAL HOUSING
CHOICE VOUCHER RECIPIENTS WHO
ARE ESPECIALLY FINANCIALLY
STRAINED AND WHOSE PARKING COSTS
WOULD OTHERWISE BE COVERED BY
THEIR VOUCHER. UNBUNDLED PARKING
LOT ALREADY EXEMPTS VARIOUS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TYPES TO
AVOID, COMPLICATE ING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCING. WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR SPONSORS FROM
LAST YEAR, STREETS FOR ALL AND
SPUR. ADDITIONALLY LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA. THE ONLY REMAINING
OPPOSITION TO AB 1317 WHEN THE
BILL PASSED OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE, SUPPORTS THIS
POLICY. AB 2898 RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, WITNESSES. WELL, LET
ME GO OVER THE PRELIMINARY
ISSUES HERE BEFORE WE GET TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION, WE'RE GOING TO USE
THE USUAL PROCEDURE HERE IN
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
WHEREBY WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WHO WILL TESTIFY IF SO DESIRED,
IN SUPPORT, TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. EACH WILL BE AFFORDED
TWO MINUTES AFTER THE PRIMARY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TESTIFY.
I'LL INVITE OTHER SUPPORTERS TO
STATE THEIR NAME, THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
AND THAT'S IT. NAME, AFFILIATION
, POSITION. AND WE'LL DO THE
SAME THING FOR THE OPPOSITION.
EACH OF THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO TESTIFY, AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE OTHERS WHO MAY
STATE THEIR NAME AND THEIR
POSITION AND THEIR AFFILIATION
IN WHAT WE TERM AS ME. TWO
TESTIMONY, IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE FURTHER INFORMATION ON
ANY BILL, YOU CAN SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE USING
ONE OF THE METHODS DESCRIBED ON
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE, ALL RIGHT. NOW LET'S
TURN TO WITNESSES ON, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARLOS AB 2898. IF YOU'RE
A WITNESS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I SEE
NO ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE, IF YOU ARE A WITNESS
OR YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I SEE NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE.
OAN. ALL RIGHT, LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. AND, OH, BY
THE WAY, WE'RE JUST LACKING ONE
MEMBER TO FORM A QUORUM. WE HAVE
100% OF THE REPUBLICANS HERE, BY
THE WAY. YES ALL RIGHT. TWICE IF
YOU WANT. LET ME LET ME RUN THAT
BY THE COMMITTEE. SO. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NIELLO,
SENATOR ASHBY IS PRESENT. SO I
APOLOGIZE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CURIEL, WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND FORM A QUORUM HERE,
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, BEFORE WE
TURN IT OVER TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO MADAM, FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM, UMBERG
HERE, WILK PRESENT WILK PRESENT.
ASHBY HERE. ASHBY. HERE.
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD HERE.
LAIRD. HERE. NILO. HERE. NILO
HERE. ROTH. ROTH. HERE. STERN
WAHAB. WIENER ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE
A THANK YOU, MISS BUXTON. WE
HAVE A QUORUM, SENATOR ASHBY.
YEAH. THANK YOU. AND SORRY, I'M
A LITTLE OUT OF BREATH. TRY TO
RUN. APPRECIATE IT,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU MADE THE BEST
EFFORT EVER TO TRY TO GET IN
TOUCH WITH ME BEFORE THIS, SO
I'M SORRY WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION FROM THE DAIS. WE
TRIED. I'LL GIVE US BOTH AN A
PLUS FOR EFFORT ON ON TRYING THE
ORIGINAL. THIS BILL IN FRONT OF
US TODAY IS AN IS AN EASY. YES.
THE ORIGINAL BILL THAT THIS BILL
TODAY IS HELPING TO CLARIFY WHY
I HAD CONCERNS WITH AND THE
REASON I HAVE CONCERNS IS
BECAUSE IT IS A BILL THAT TAKES
TEN COUNTIES AND CREATES ONE SET
OF RULES AND REGULATIONS FOR
THEM AND LEAVES THE OTHER 48
WITH SOMETHING DIFFERENT. THE
REASON I THINK THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC IS BECAUSE EITHER
YOUR BILL IS GOING TO BE
BRILLIANT AND WORK SWIMMINGLY
FOR THOSE TEN COUNTIES, AND THEN
48 COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE LEFT
OUT OF THAT, OR IT'S NOT GOING
TO WORK. AND THE TEN COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO HAVE HIGHER RATES
THAN THE OTHER 48 COUNTIES.
EITHER WAY, I WANT I WANT YOUR
BILL TO BE REVIEWED, BECAUSE IF
IT'S WORKING GREAT FOR THE TEN
COUNTIES, THEN I WANT ALL 58
COUNTIES TO BENEFIT. AND IF IT'S
NOT WORKING FOR THE TEN
COUNTIES, WHICH INCLUDES ALL
MILLION OF MY CONSTITUENTS
CGRTS, THEN I DON'T WANT IT TO
STICK WITH THEM. AND HAVE A
BENEFIT BE TO THE OTHER 48
COUNTIES AND SO I TALKED TO YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS LAST
YEAR, BUT IT WAS REALLY LATE IN
THE PROCESS. AND WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO DO, OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO ON
THIS COMMITTEE HERE, BUT I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO CONSIDER AND
I THINK IT WOULD BE IN YOUR OWN
BEST INTEREST, THAT WHEN THIS
GOES TO APPROPRIATE NEXT THAT
YOU ASK THAT AN AUDIT BE DONE ON
YOUR BILL IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
OUT SO THAT THEY CAN REVIEW
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S WORKING,
BECAUSE IF IT IS WORKING, IT
OUGHT TO BE STATEWIDE POLICY.
AND IF IT IS NOT WORKING, WE
SHOULD NOT BE HANDICAPPING,
THUSLY, MAKING RENTS HIGHER IN
TEN COUNTIES BECAUSE OF A POLICY
THAT'S IN PLACE. SO I'M ASKING
YOU, I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY NO MATTER WHAT YOU
DO. BUT I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CONSIDER MAKING THAT
AUTHOR AMENDMENT IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO HELP WITH YOU IN ANY WAY. I
AM ON APPROPRIATIONS. I'D BE
HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT IT
THERE, TOO. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SOME CARILLO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND NOW OR IN YOUR
CLOSE? I CAN RESPOND IN MY
CLOSE. IS FINE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
? SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, IS THERE A, ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR WILK MOVES THE BILL,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS AND,
SENATOR, APPRECIATE, OUR DUE
DILIGENCE IN TRYING TO CONNECT
WITH EACH OTHER, GIVEN THE SHORT
NOTICE, WE CONSIDERED IN AB
1317, WHICH WAS ALREADY SIGNED
INTO LAW, WHICH, RELATED TO THIS
POLICY, BUT NOT THIS POLICY
ENTIRELY ABOUT A STATEWIDE WIDE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS BILL
STATEWIDE. IN FACT, IT'S
ACTUALLY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HAD TALKED
TO US ABOUT AS WELL. AND WE ALSO
DISCUSSED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
CENSUS OR A STUDY POLICY RELATED
TO LOOKING AT THIS BILL. AND WE
DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
VERY DIFFERENT DIRECTION ON AB
1317. SO UNFORTUNATELY, WILL NOT
BE CONSIDERING THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND APPROPRIATIONS, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE BUDGET SITUATION THAT
THE STATE FINDS ITSELF IN,
LOOKING AT A STUDY WILL
POTENTIALLY INCUR INCREDIBLE
COST TO AB 1317 THAT I THINK
RIGHT NOW, UNFORTUNATELY, THE
STATE, MAY NOT BE IN A IN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. SO AND THE ONLY REASON
WHY I, I SAY THAT NOT AT THIS
TIME IS BECAUSE THE BILL THAT
YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU IS NOT
THE POLICY FOR AB 1317, THE BILL
THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU IS
RELATED TO HELPING ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH VOUCHERS HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE THE
HELP AND SUPPORT THEY NEED, AND
THAT VETERANS AREN'T HAVING TO
DOUBLE PAY, FOR PARKING IN
SITUATIONS WHERE UNBUNDLED
PARKING IS HAS ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED. SO TOTALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
SUPPORT. I THINK, AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND WE LOOK AT OTHER
POLICIES RELATED TO PARKING,
MAYBE THERE'S SOME OTHER EFFORTS
THAT CAN BE MADE, BUT WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT IN OUR PROCESS. AND
WHAT WAS NEGOTIATED IN AB 1317,
WHICH WAS ALREADY SIGNED INTO
LAW. SO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? SEEING
NONE, THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY
SENATOR WILK, YOU'VE CLOSED. SO,
MADAM OR MISS BUXTON, WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE? ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, MEASURE AB 2898. DO
PASS UMBERG I UMBERG I WILK I
WILK I ASHBY I ASHBY I CABALLERO
. DURAZZO. LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO
NILO I ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB
WIENER. 660. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HERE, I'M GOING TO
PRESENT AB 3072, AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI NORRIS,
WHO COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK.
I LIKE THAT.
OKAY. UP NEXT IS ITEM 15 AB 3072
BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN PETRI NORRIS IS
GOING TO BE, PRESENTED BY OUR
ESTEEMED CHAIR AND WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF Dð Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED. SENATOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
3072 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS TO HELP
KEEP KEEP KIDS SAFE DURING
CUSTODY BATTLES. THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS, AND, AND
ILLUSTRATE DURING CURRENT UNDER
CURRENT LAW, GENERALLY LIMITS
EXIST WHEN A COURT CAN MAKE AN
EX PARTE CUSTODY ORDER EXCEPT
FOR WHEN THE CHILD, WHERE IT'S
BEEN DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE IS
AN IMMEDIATE RISK OF HARM TO THE
CHILD. AB 3072 DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST, IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT
WHEN A COURT IS DETERMINING IF
THERE'S A RISK OF IMMEDIATE HARM
, THEY SHOULD CONSIDER A
PARENT'S ILLEGAL ACCESS TO
FIREARMS. SECOND, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE COURT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD, ARE BETTER SERVED BY
LIMITING OR SUSPENDING
VISITATION BY REQUIRING VIRTUAL
VISITATION. THIS WILL HELP
PREVENT VIOLENCE AND KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE DURING CUSTODY
BATTLES. WITH ME. HERE IS MISS
MINER, ON BEHALF OF GIFFORDS,
AARON NÚMERO. ACTUALLY, TODAY,
ON BEHALF OF GIFFORDS, WE'RE A
NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE PROTECTION
ORGANIZATION. AND BASICALLY AS
THE AS MR. CHAIR SAID DURING EX
PARTE CUSTODY ORDERS, THERE IS
THERE'S ALWAYS THE RISK THAT,
THAT THERE IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
REQUIRES A COURT TO CONSIDER A
PARENT'S ILLEGAL ACCESS TO
FIREARMS. IN ADDITION TO THAT,
IT AUTHORIZES A COURT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER LIMITING OR
SUSPENDING VISITATION OR
REQUIRING VIRTUAL VISITATION IS
BETTER FOR THE CHILD'S SAFETY.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM THAT WANT TO WANTS TO
PROVIDE ME TWO TESTIMONY. COME
ON UP. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. AND THAT
YOU STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
MELISSA KNIGHT FINE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION TO PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE. AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM?
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL? SEEING NONE. WE'LL PULL
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS. SEEING NONE
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION. SO IN
YOUR OPENING, YOU DIDN'T MENTION
ABOUT HOW HARD THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKED ON ON
THIS BILL. SO THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION IS THAT JUDICIARY STAFF
ALWAYS WORKS VERY HARD ON EVERY
BILL. OKAY. VERY GOOD. SO WITH
THAT, GO AHEAD AND GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE. I URGE AN AYE VOTE OKAY.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT CAN WE CALL
THE ROLL. OH WE HAVE A MOTION
YET. SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU. I
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE SENATOR
ARCHULETA HERE TO HELP US. SO
ITEM NUMBER 15, MEASURE AB 3072
DO PASS, AS AMENDED. UMBERG
UMBERG I WILK I WILK I ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO DE ROSSO.
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO I NILO I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB.
WIENER OKAY, THAT'S 6 TO 0 AND
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. WITH THAT
HAPPILY TURN THE GAVEL BACK OVER
TO THE CHAIR.
SO MOVED BY WILK. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR WILK HAS MOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MISS BUXTON,
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL CONSENT
CALENDAR TO BE ADOPTED? UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZO. LAIRD. LAIRD
AYE. NILO. NILO. AYE. ROTH. ROTH
AYE. STERN. WAHAB. WIENER ALL
RIGHT. WHAT'S THE VOTE? SIX
ZERO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
OKAY. WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS,
ONE BY SOME MEMBER. RENDON ITEM
NUMBER 16 AND ANOTHER BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. ITEM
NUMBER 18, AB 1815. AN.
WITH THE CONSENT OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GRACIOUSNESS, IN ACCEPTING
THE ROLE OF PRESENTER ON ITEM
NUMBER 16, AB 2399, AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD. I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A GOOD 12 SECONDS TO
PREPARE. GO AHEAD. I WAS GOING
TO SAY, AFTER LENGTHY
CONTEMPLATION, I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2399 THAT WOULD
INCREASE AWARENESS ABOUT THE
MOBILE HOME PROTECTION, THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW
PROTECTION PROGRAM BY REQUIRING
THAT MOBILE HOME TENANTS RECEIVE
AN ANNUAL NOTICE OUTLINING THE
LEGAL SERVICES AVAILABLE, THEY
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS OFTEN DO
NOT KNOW WHAT RIGHTS THEY HAVE
UNDER THIS AND WHAT EXISTS TO
PROTECT THEM AGAINST THINGS LIKE
RENT INCREASES WITHOUT NOTICE
AND ILLEGAL EVICTION. AND THE
IRONY IS NOW THAT I AM
CONTEMPLATING THIS BILL, I WROTE
THE LATEST BILL THAT WAS ENACTED
INTO LAW RELATING TO THE MOBILE
HOME RENT CONTROL, RESTRICTIONS
AND THIS ALL IS DESPITE THE
PROGRAM BEING FUNDED BY
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM MOBILE HOME
TENANTS THEMSELVES. EVERY YEAR,
AN ANNUAL NOTICE IS ISSUED TO
MOBILE HOME TENANTS OUTLINING
THEIR RIGHTS. THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE PARK OWNERS. THIS WOULD
ADD A PROVISION TO THAT ANNUAL
NOTICE EXPLAINING WHAT THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW
PROTECTION PROGRAM IS, HOW IT
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF MOBILE
HOME TENANTS, AND INFORMATION ON
HOW TO UTILIZE THE PROGRAM. HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS MICHELLE. I BELIEVE IT'S
MONNING WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS LEAGUE
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MICHELLE MONNING
CLOSE THOUGH, WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE MOBILE HOME MANUFACTURERS
OWNERS LEAGUE IN SUPPORT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT RELEASED
THEIR ANNUAL REPORT IN MARCH OF
2023. THAT REPORT INCLUDED DATA
ON THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW
PROTECTION PROGRAM THAT WAS
REQUIRED TO BE PUBLISHED UNDER
THE LAW, THAT WE WORKED WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN ON BACK IN 2018.
THE MRP IS A PROGRAM THAT WE PAY
FOR TO PROTECT OURSELVES FROM
PARK OWNERS WHO VIOLATE THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LAW, THE
2023 HCD REPORT HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED FOR OUTREACH TO MOBILE HOME
HOMEOWNERS REGARDING THE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENCY LAW PROTECTION
PROGRAM, AND ENSURING THAT
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS RECEIVE
NOTICE OF THE MRP IS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP TO THIS OUTREACH. THE
ANNUAL NOTICE WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED ALONG WITH OTHER
ANNUAL NOTICES ALREADY REQUIRED
BY EXISTING LAW. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2399.
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING, NOW
NOW LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2399, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU, MR. GOVERNOR. THANK
YOU. APPLAUSE. YOURS, ANDREW.
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF MMA,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
WE CREATED THE TOP TEN LIST WITH
SENATOR, ACTUALLY, ASSEMBLYWOMAN
TONI ATKINS, Ã TRYING TO
PROVIDE AN ABBREVIATED LIST FOR
RESIDENTS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS, WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE UNDER THE MRL, WE DID THAT
TO CREATE A TOP TEN. SO YOU HAVE
A SUCCINCT LIST BY ADDING
ANOTHER ONE, WE'D ACTUALLY HAVE
OTHER IDEAS THAT WE'D LIKE TO
ADD TO THE LIST. AND THE WHOLE
POINT WAS NOT TO CONTINUE TO
GROW IT, WE ALREADY HAVE TO
NOTICE THE MLRP WHEN WE CHARGE
RESIDENTS FOR THE $10. AND JUST
SO YOU KNOW, OVER 95% OF THE
COMPLAINTS RECEIVED HAVE PROVED
TO BE INVALIDATED BY HCD'S OWN
STANDARDS. THE PROGRAM IS 95%
BELOW EXPECTATIONS. THEY'VE
RECEIVED 5000 COMPLAINTS OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS. THEY
EXPECTED TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE
OVER 4000 COMPLAINTS TO REFER ON
TO AN LSP. FURTHERMORE FOR ONE
THIRD OF THE COMPLAINTS LISTED
ARE ACTUALLY FROM THE TOP TEN
LIST. SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS ACTUALLY UNNECESSARY AT
THIS POINT. AND AS A MATTER OF
FACT, WE BELIEVE THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE SUNSETTED IN TWO
YEARS. AND THEN FINALLY, WHY ARE
WE ADDING SOMETHING TO A LIST
FOR A BILL THAT'S ACTUALLY
SUNSETTING IN TWO YEARS, FOR
WHICH IF THE PROGRAM IS NOT
RENEWED, WILL SIMPLY THEN HAVE
TO REDO THE LIST AND REMOVE THE
POINT. SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION. OAN. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION, LET ME ASK A QUICK
QUESTION, MR. GOVERNOR. MR.
GOVERNOR, IS THE ENTIRE BILL
SUNSETTING IN TWO YEARS, THE
ENTIRE LAW, THE MLP PROGRAM IS
THEY JUST DID A THREE YEAR
EXTENSION. SO THE ENTIRE PROGRAM
GOES AWAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OKAY, QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING. YES. SEN NIELLO,
BECAUSE SENATOR LAIRD WAS JUST
PRESSED INTO DUTY. I'M NOT GOING
TO ASK. PROBING QUESTIONS, BUT
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THE
ARGUMENTS THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
REALLY NOT NEEDED AND EFFECTIVE
AS THINGS STAND NOW, FOR ONLY A
YEAR. IT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE OF A
BILL THAT REALLY DOESN'T NEED TO
BE IMPOSED. SENATOR LAIRD, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND OR WOULD YOU
LIKE YOUR WITNESS TO RESPOND, OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO JUST. I'LL
HANDLE IT IN THE CLOSE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IS
THERE A MOTION, SENATOR WAHAB
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD SAY TO MY
MISPRONUNCIATION OF MY OWN
WITNESSES NAME, THE WAY HER NAME
IS PRONOUNCED IS THE WAY SENATOR
MANNING'S NAME WAS MISPRONOUNCED
FOR EIGHT YEARS. SO I APPRECIATE
THE CIRCULAR PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION. AND AND, AND ONE
VERY FLIP WAY TO RESPOND TO ONE
OF THE THINGS IS, IS THE AUTHOR
IS TERMING OUT AND HE WON'T BE
HERE IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS, AND
HE'S GOING TO GET THIS DONE
BEFORE HE LEAVES. AND I THINK
THAT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT POINT.
AND, AND MR. GOVERNOR, WHO I'VE
HAD VERY FRIENDLY EXCHANGES WITH
ON MY MOBILE HOME BILLS, HE VERY
CAREFULLY DIDN'T SAY THE NUMBER
OF, OF CLAIMS THAT WERE
DISALLOWED OR THE, COMPLAINTS
WERE DISALLOWED BECAUSE 5% WERE
ALLOWED. AND THAT IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBER AS A RAW
NUMBER AND SO I THINK THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL BE MORE THAN WILLING
TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OPPONENT. THIS IS A NEEDED
BILL, AND I WOULD ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU,
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION BY
SENATOR WAHAB, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS ITEM
NUMBER 16, AB 2399. DO PASS
UMBERG I UMBERG I WILK ASHBY I
ASHBY I CABALLERO DURAZZO. LAIRD
Ó I LAIRD I NILO. NILO NØ.
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB. WAHAB
I WIENER. FIVE. FIVE. 5 TO 1. 5
TO 1. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. AND I SEE
DOCTOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
HERE, FOR OUR FINAL BILL. SO IF
YOU ARE LISTENING OR YOU'RE IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE, THIS WOULD BE
A GOOD TIME TO PRESENT YOURSELF
TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT, DOCTOR
WEBER, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WE, FIRST, I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1815, THE EXPANSION
OF THE ORIGINAL CROWN ACT OF
2019. WE ALL REMEMBER THAT CROWN
STANDS FOR CREATING A RESPECTFUL
AND OPEN WORKPLACE FOR NATURAL
HAIR. THE CROWN ACT PROHIBITED
HAIR DISCRIMINATION UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT AND THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE. IT WAS TRULY
GROUNDBREAKING, AS IT WAS THE
FIRST LAW IN THIS NATION TO
PROHIBIT SUCH DISCRIMINATION.
THÀNH AB 1815 WILL EXPAND THIS
LAW TO INCLUDE COMPETITIVE
SPORTS FROM SPORTS CLUBS OR
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS, ENSURING
THAT ATHLETES IN CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT BE SUBJECT TO DISCRIMINATION
AND EXCLUSION BASED ON THEIR
NATURAL HAIR. STORIES HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY COME TO LIGHT FROM
ALL OVER THE NATION, RANGING
FROM STUDENT ATHLETES TO
EMPLOYEES WITHIN A PROFESSIONAL
SETTING. BEING ASKED TO CHANGE
THEIR NATURAL HAIR. THESE ARE
INCREDIBLY DEHUMANIZING
EXPERIENCES, AS OUR HAIR IS A
SYMBOL OF WHO WE ARE AND PEOPLE
DESERVE TO SHOW UP AT SCHOOL.
WORKPLACE A SUPREME COURT, OR
EVEN THE STATE LEGISLATURE, OR A
YOUNG ATHLETE AT A SPORTING
EVENT AS THEIR WHOLE SELVES.
THESE CASES THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE EXACTLY
WHY THE CALIFORNIA REPARATIONS
TASK FORCE MADE THIS EXPANSION.
ONE OF THEIR POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXTEND THE REACH
OF THE ORIGINAL CROWN ACT TO
EXPLICITLY INCLUDE COMPETITIVE
SPORTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY, 1815 WILL
ACCOMPLISH THIS BY AMENDING THE
UNRUH ACT. IN THE SAME WAY VÀ
AND THE EDUCATION CODE WERE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE THIS
DEFINITION OF RACE MAKING SURE
THAT THIS IS APPLIED TO ALL
BUSINESSES, NONPROFITS, OR
NON-BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE OPEN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS, BLACK EQUITY
COLLECTIVE, AND NAACP AND
OTHERS. WITH ME HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS BRANDON GREEN FROM
THE WESTERN LAW, WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON,
BRANDON GREEN, DIRECTOR OF
POLICY ADVOCACY AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OBVIOUSLY, WE ARE SPONSORS.
CLEARLY, I'M A PERSON WITH A
NATURAL HAIRSTYLE, THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE MOST KIDS ARE
PLAYING SPORTS OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL CONTEXT, INCLUDING MY OWN
CHILDREN WHO PLAY COMPETITIVE
SOCCER AND GYMNASTICS. KIDS AT
AN EARLY AGE GET VARIOUS
MESSAGES ABOUT THEIR IDENTITY,
ABOUT THEIR HAIR, ETC. AND SO
PLACING SOMETHING, IN LAW THAT
WILL PROTECT THEM FROM
DISCRIMINATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT. THE CURRENT SOCIAL,
POLITICAL CLIMATE THAT WE'RE IN,
UNDER WHICH VARIOUS THINGS ARE
UNDER ATTACK, RENDER THIS BILL
BOTH TIMELY AND NECESSARY, AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS. SAM
NASH, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALICIA BENAVIDES, ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALASKA, ON BEHALF OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE OPPOSITION
. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1815,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
ON GOING ONCE, GOING TWICE,
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. SENATOR ASHBY HAS
MOVED THE BILL, OKAY, DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS. OH, YES. SENATOR
CABALLERO, I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. I, HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE SOME VIDEOS POSTED ONLINE
OF SOME KIDS THAT, YOUNG KIDS
THAT WERE, VILIFIED FOR THEIR
HAIR AND MADE TO CUT IT IN WAYS
THAT WERE REALLY HUMILIATING.
AND I THINK IT'S, OUTRAGEOUS.
AND SO I, I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL, BUT ALSO SAY THAT, THERE'S
SOME EDUCATION THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN, AND MAYBE THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL, THE BIGGEST BENEFIT OF
THE BILL WOULD BE THE EDUCATION
PROCESS. SO I AGREE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHERS SEEING NO ONE ELSE. ALL
RIGHT. THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR BILLS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ASHBY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. WELL, AGAIN, I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK AND FOR ALLOWING US
TO PRESENT THE BILL TODAY, THIS
BILL IS A BLACK CAUCUS PRIORITY,
AND IT'S ALSO A VERY PERSONAL TO
ME. I DO ALSO HAVE TWO YOUNG
BOYS WHO ARE VERY ACTIVE IN
SPORTS, AND MY OLDEST IS GROWING
HIS HAIR OUT SO HE CAN LOCK IT
LIKE MINE. SO, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
YOU HAVE BRAIDS OR LOCKS OR
TWIST OR CURLS, ALL FORMS OF
NATURAL HAIR BELONG IN ALL
SPACES WITHOUT ANY ALTERATION
STATION TO MEET ANYONE ELSE'S
COMFORT LEVEL. AND WITHOUT THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 1815.
DO PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. UMBERG
I UMBERG I WILK ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO I CABALLERO I DURAZO.
LAIRD I LAIRD I NILO NILO I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB I
WAHAB I WIENER. HI WIENER I. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO. IT'S
EIGHT ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL. WE'RE MISSING SOME
MEMBERS IN A MOMENT. WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL FOR A FINAL
TIME. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BRYANT HERE AND JOAN SAWYER,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
ARE YOU HERE FOR MORAL SUPPORT?
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WELL WE ALL FEEL
SUPPORTED. SO THANK YOU, ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO WAIT JUST A MOMENT OR
TWO. WE ARE MISSING MEMBERS WHO
ARE IN OTHER COMMITTEES.
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT? LET'S
DO THIS. LET'S CALL THE ROLL
RIGHT NOW FOR THOSE THAT ARE
HERE, AND THEN WE'LL WAIT AGAIN,
SO. ALL RIGHT, SO, SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. STARTING
WITH CONSENT CALENDAR TO BE
ADOPTED. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. DURAZO STERN. STERN. AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. TEN ZERO MISSING.
ONE MEMBER WILL PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. ITEM BILL.
EXCUSE ME. ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
2898. DO PASS. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE DURAZO. STERN A
STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER HI. WIENER. AYE. TEN
ZERO. WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. ITEM NUMBER 15,
AB 3072. DO PASS AS AMENDED.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. HI. WIENER. AYE TEN
ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT
BACK ON. CALL ITEM NUMBER 16 AB
2399. DO PASS CHAIR VOTING AYE.
WILK CABALLERO. AYE. DARAZO
STERN A STERN AYE. WIENER
CABALLERO. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. 818. WAIT, WAIT.
OKAY, LET'S DO THIS AGAIN. LET'S
CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
SORRY. OKAY. ON THIS BILL. OKAY
ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2399 WILK
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE. DURAZO
STERN. STERN. AYE. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. TO ONE. 8 TO 1.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT BACK ON.
CALL ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. LAST
BILL. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. ITEM
NUMBER 18 AB 1815. ACTION Dð
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WILK
BARRASSO. STERN A STERN. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. NINE ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT BACK ON CALL.
I THINK THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS. WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE
MORE MEMBER, LET ME. OKAY. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. WE'RE AWAITING JUST ONE
MORE MEMBER WITH YOU. YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2399 Dð PASS.
WILK. WHO'S THE AUTHOR? NØ WILK
NÓ DURAZO. 8 TO 2, WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THAT BACK ON CALL. I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES, OH. I'M
SORRY, OKAY. GO AHEAD. ITEM
NUMBER 18, ITEM NUMBER 18 AB
1815. DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WILK I
WILK I. TEN ZERO OKAY. WE'RE
PUTTING THAT BACK ON CALL. SO
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF
BREAK HERE, AND THEN WE WILL
RECONVENE, WHEN THE, FINAL
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE HAS HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S OPEN UP THE
ROLL HERE AND CALL THE ROLL ONE
FINAL TIME. ALL RIGHT. CONSENT
CALENDAR TO BE ADOPTED. SO ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. YES, I
THOUGHT SO. I 11 ZERO, THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 2898. DO
PASS ISO I BARRASSO I 11 ZERO
BILLS OUT ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 3072
DO PASS AS AMENDED. SO I 11 ZERO
BILLS OUT. ITEM NUMBER 16 AB
2399 DO PASS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
. NINE TWO BILLS OUT. ITEM
NUMBER 18 AB 1815 DO PASS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I 11 ZERO BILL
IS OUT OKAY. WE ARE DONE. WE ARE
CONCLUDED TODAY. WE'LL RECONVENE
NEXT WEEK, FOR A LITTLE
LENGTHIER HEARING. SO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ADJOURNED.